Markel reaction brazen what do you think
I mean absolute uncertainty and that's
what the market hates and I think it's
we're in a very manipulative situation
right now because there's the political
aspects on both sides of the ocean and
how corporations deal with those
circumstances are going to influence
what happens going forward in the UK and
also here in our election and what I'm
talking about is if all of a sudden we
see JP Morgan and all these different
big financial companies say you know
what we're just moving everybody to
Berlin all but now there's a tangible
impact on jobs and that's going to
influence a conversation and it's the
same in the United States once you know
we see that you know we're talking about
all this nationalism you know you know
Trump versus you know senator Clinton or
Secretary of State Clinton now if all
these businesses are reacting to this
take back our country movement by
leaving that sets the tone for the
election as well look if it happened
that all these company said we're out
why would it be any different here but
on the flip side if the United States is
open and we adhere to our treaties then
all of a sudden tech companies in
particular in the UK who want to be able
to work with the European Union and have
the treaties already in place they might
come here and if you see a big movement
of tech companies here because you know
there's no better tech you know
foundation and employee base in customer
base than United States protect we might
say a wholesale influ of those companies
which in one on one end says to the UK
corrects it was a big mistake and it
also sends the message to our economy
and to us voters that protectionism and
cutting off those treaties would be a
huge mistake you mention immigration I
mean that's a certainly a big part of it
in the UK and it's a big part of the
nationalist discussion is happening
really led by Donald Trump yeah I mean
look immigration takes a lot of
different forms there's um high-end you
know for visas for employees that you
can't get theirs you know people being
concerned about their lives concerned
about their jobs i am not a fan of
Donald Trump's approach you know I'm a
tech guy I mean
invested in companies that allow for or
create the ability to test and evaluate
people before they come at company
called come Varys and that we're working
we've worked in Israel and southern
American companies that say okay before
you come into this country we're going
to put you through this test and we're
going to ask you these series of
questions and we can tell with a high
degree of accuracy eighty-five percent
and there will learn to be better on
whether or not you're going to have a
negative impact whether or not you're a
terrorist whether or not you're you know
radical Islamic terror you want to
define people so there's technology I
think that our first steps that
everybody is ignoring and so I would
just take a completely different
approach are you concerned with the tone
though the national suit on whether it's
in the in the UK or here absolutely it's
scary right I mean look in my mind hate
never hate never accomplishes anything
no one's ever won with hate and I think
that's the fundamental problem and hate
doesn't solve problems it doesn't
improve the economy hate doesn't make
people um doesn't protect our people
anymore doesn't protect the borders
anymore and so we've got to be very
careful about the verbiage we use
because it's just that there's no win
there